[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
puisque les histoires policières sont à
la mode
je vais vous en raconter une il faut
vous dire qu'il ya quelques temps nous
avions fait la connaissance d'un chien
policier
ils s'étaient égarés nous lui avons
indiqué son chemin en échange il nous a
raconté quelques histoires mais moins
intéressante que celle ci tous les
matins quand elles sont en vacances les
petites conduisent les vaches auprès
vous avez fini de remplir mon panier
nous avons encore celui du chien
il pourrait bien se débrouiller seul jeu
le type de procès pour moi je pourrais
bien crever tétouan et vous veillez à ce
que les bêtes n'aillent pas se gonfler
dans les trèfles ou croquer des pommes
aux abords du chemin
pensez que vous n'êtes plus des petites
filles à l'idée on pourrait presque
ineffables ne réplique pas toujours et
toi fignon de chiens tâche de faire
attention aussi toujours des compliments
je ne change pas où les vaches penser
quand vous avoir brouté l'herbe qui ne
coûte rien à perdre et pas une bouchée
soyez tranquilles par an oui pour manger
on mangera ne mangerai mieux si on
n'était pas toujours dérangé déranger
corn hot mais qui donne dérange je dis
ce que je dis alors on s'en va oui ou
non on s'en va ce soir les parents
pourquoi la corde et a dit qu'elle était
toujours dérangé voilà une chose qu'il
faudra tirer au clair
et toujours pareil ces gamines sont de
vraies têtes folles heureusement il y à
la cornette si raisonnable et si dévoués
l'ouvrier la petite carrenet et la
petite troupe s'en fut vers les prêts
on va
cornet de bouder déjà et marche est
assez loin derrière ses camarades
[Musique]
si tu n'avances pas plus vite je peux
membres elle pas si tu me touches je le
dirai aux parents
[Musique]
dur tous les jours les vaches au chant
tu appelles ça dès maintenant
la raison il ya là la montagne un nom à
la mer à la montagne c'est pas la peine
de discuter quand on n'ira ni à l'une ni
à l'autre
où
un peu plus loin la vache ou c'est la
vache blanche qui était maintenant loin
devant la cornette rencontrèrent un
pommier pas l'épreuve en furent vie de
gober naturellement les petites vous ont
laissé manger des pommes
tu es jaloux parce qu'il ne reste plus
pour toi je vais lui dire aux parents si
tu fais ça non aujourd'hui un peu plus
loin la troupe passa devant des
[ __ ]
enfin avant d'arriver à destination la
troupe passe à encore devant une ferme
les deux petites en connaissait bien les
propriétaires qui ne leur paraissait pas
très sympathique
je lis moi je dis oui
joli bâches et les petites nédon
jusqu'ici vous avez vu les [ __ ]
n'est pas vain méfiez vous de ces gens
là c'est du monde qui est bon à rien qui
est capable de tout merci du
renseignement finalement les bêtes
arrivèrent au près ils restèrent toute
la journée
l'herbe était grasse et il faisait beau
[Musique]
mais comme l'herbe n'intéressait pas les
petites
après avoir épuisé tous les jeux qu'elle
connaissait elle finir par s'ennuyer
[Musique]
win32 des frais en effet elles
trouvèrent beaucoup de fraises dans le
bois mais quand elles revinrent la
cornette avait disparu tiens c'est vrai
où étaient en route et on n'a pas fait
attention on ne peut pas faire deux
choses à la fois j'ai fait un petit
somme chaque retrait pendant ce temps là
elle a dû rentrer à la ferme toute seule
elle nous fait la tête depuis ce matin
[Musique]
bien nous sommes joly heureusement mes
parents sont pas encore entrés ont volé
le père de rien pour attendre
voilà les parents
je voudrais tranche illustre ali ne vous
inquiétez pas j'ai fait le nécessaire
mais aussi à ne peut pas remplacer une
vache ci ne dit rien à vos parents je ne
suis pas dvd coûte ainsi il faut
toujours écouter les bêtes
[Musique]
bonjour alors tout s'est bien passé
très bien m'a pas mis les bâtons étaient
sages des papas voit aussi comme
toujours
comme toujours à vous m'inquiéter je
vais aller voir ce qu'en pensent les
bêtes ont trouvé un peu pâlotte vous
avez peut-être fait non on n'a pas faim
alors la journée a été belle une journée
superbe une herbe
je ne me lasse pas de la ruminer et la
corne est elle est là
évidemment vous voulez vous qu'elle soit
et qui pourrait venir me dire bonsoir
cornette
elle est en train de lécher le blog de
sel vous savez qu'il lui faut beaucoup
d'eux seuls
j'aimerais tout de même qu'elle me dit
si la journée s'est bien passée
tu n'entends cornette
je vous entends excusez moi je ne pas me
déranger qui a une drôle de voix
cornette claude l'abreuvoir et était un
peu froide je suis lent river alors tout
s'est vraiment bien passé maintenant il
ya ce seul chien qui m'a appuyé ennuyé
mais après tout il fait son travail
la journée semble avoir été vraiment
bonne je viens de parler à corne est
maladroite
tu ne peux pas faire attention ramasse
marinette voilà tout s'est très bien
passé
ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai encore une is
et j'avoue très tard il fait beau la
corne est déjà parti comment ça elle
avait mal à la tête et pour ainsi dire
pas de l'est elle a demandé à marine et
de l'emmener au prêt dès lors aux
navettes déteste ces valeurs la cornette
a été la réveiller
[Musique]
ou bien nous avons perdu une vache voilà
ce que c'est que de ne pas avoir d'
ordre sa place j'irais voir du côté des
[ __ ] puisqu'on te le dis
[Musique]
j'ai perdu une vache vous l'auriez pas
trouvé et où l'aurions-nous mise dans
notre roulotte
excusez moi qu'est ce qu'elle voulait la
petite halle a perdu sa vache un peu
plus tard avec la vache rousse la
blanche et le chien delphine rejoignit
sa soeur paraît de plus risquent sinon
je pleure moi aussi pendant la plus
grande partie de la journée elle attend
dire la cornette pensant que celle-ci
bout d où leur avait joué un mauvais
tour
[Musique]
arrivé quelque chose avec ornette il est
peut-être entrer dans le boue et s'y est
perdu il faut aller voir
on va chercher la corne est dans le
droit je vous accompagne
wima chemin des mas tension a expliqué
raisonnable soyez tranquille vous pouvez
nous faire confiance et korn est demeuré
invisible et pour comble deviner ce que
vivent les petites filles quand elles
revers dans le près rien elle ne vire
plus rien les deux autres vaches avaient
disparu à leur tour suffit arrêtez de
sangloter
ce qu'il faut c'est gagner du temps
heureusement il fait nuit et vos parents
ne sont pas encore là si votre père veut
salir les tables je demanderai un coup
de main aux canards et aux chats plus
tout coup de voix j'y vais
sa chérie tu peux pas faire attention
non excusez-moi lama lantern et est
maintenant
alors mesdames comment s'est passée la
journée très bien la rouge ce matin
n'avaient pas très bonne mine
comment ça va ce soir un coin commencent
à pointer cet imbécile de canard qui est
venu se fourrer dans mes pattes vouvry
très bien ce soir ne vous inquiétez pas
très bien alors bonne nuit en nuit il
fera jour je vais leur parler au coq au
lever du soleil le coq avait bien du mal
à se retenir de chanter il le fallait
bien pourtant pas pourrait chanter pour
te dira c'est une chance que vos parents
ne se réveille au chant du coq
on lui demandera de chanter dans un
monde et le chat d'irak vous êtes déjà
parti avec les vaches et moi ça nous
donnera encore la journée pour retrouver
les vaches
comment les retrouver j'y ai réfléchi
j'ai beaucoup parlé vous le savez un
médecin chiens policiers
il m'a dit que c'était avant tout une
question de cellules grises il faut les
faire fonctionner qu'est ce que c'est
l'effet les griffes ne m'interrompez pas
et suivez plutôt mon raisonnement si les
vaches ont été volés elles l'ont été par
des voleurs
en effet et d'autre part ça c'est une
chose bien connu que les voleurs ils
sont mal habillés ils pourraient voler
pour bien s'habiller
allez vous me laissez parler je
conclurai par une simple question quels
sont les gens les plus mal habillés du
pays
les bohémiens que vous avez rencontrés
alors attendez moi au prix et avant
qu'il soit l'âge d'un cochon de lait je
vous ramène le troupeau ben oui il
aurait bien ri fin par exemple il me
faudrait une fausse barbe quoi faire
pour qu'on ne me reconnaisse pas je peux
chanter maintenant temps que je sois
parti avec les petites
[Musique]
je sais tout c'est de la chance
où sont elles issa plus var inutile de
nier
1 parce que tu nous prends pour des
valeurs 1 ça ne va pas se passer comme
ça et pourquoi pas chez nous bien
volontiers vous êtes bien aimable
[Musique]
on
ans
en
le cochon n'est pas là il a disparu
aussi voici tout est perdu c'est bien le
cas de la dire
dia
gobé un poils de la barbe du cochon
voici un autre et un autre le cochon à
jour petit poucet avec sa barbe
les poils nous conduisent tout droit à
la ferme des voisins
[Musique]
entrant je sens que nous brûle ou non
donc
oh
oui
et
on n'entend pas qu'est ce que vous
faites là on suit des poils de barbe
votre chien est d'entrer chez moi je
vous prie de le rappeler on ne peut rien
ordonné un autre chat n'en fut jamais
qu'à sa tête
vous n'auriez pas vu notre cochon par
hasard notre cochon et 9 ans non moi
quand on me prend à dire à mensonge je
reçois un coup de pied je viens de voir
le cochon ou trois vaches dans l'écurie
de ces gens c'était pour rire
avant-hier l'accord la défense me
demander de l'héberger elle voulait vous
faire une feinte et les autres vaches
j'ai eu peur que la cornette s'ennuie
j'ai pensé à lui chercher sa compagnie
et le cochon c'était pour le soigner
vous me prenez pour des bottes je veux
dire pour des idiots tu as raison pas
pour des bêtes vont lui vient
[Musique]
peu après les petites qui s'étaient
attardés à jouer sur la route
regagnèrent la maison alors comme ça la
cornette on a voulu nous faire une farce
je ne voulais pas rester au mail lui le
voisin mart la rouge et moi la voisine
est venue nous chercher en nous disant
que la cornette était malade
de quoi parlez vous j'ai jamais vu
d'enfants et d'animaux aussi bavard je
vais vous raconter ce qui s'est passé
tout d'ailleurs avec la faute des
petites et du chien
figurez vous qu avant entière pour
cornette perd complètement la tête
elle vient de me raconter qu'elle a été
séquestré deux jours moi je sais bien
que je lui ai parlé tout les soifs on
dirait qu'il n'a qu'une idée faire punir
les petites et le chien si la cornette
par la tête
il vaut mieux s'en débarrasser oui je la
mènerai chez le boucher demain qu'en
pensez-vous les petites